you guys seem to really like these
thumbnails I've been drawing lately so I
figured I'd show you how I draw them
while imposing upon myself the ultimate
drawing challenge that will no doubt
prove that I am the greatest artist
who's ever lived
either that or humiliate me what you're
seeing now is me drawing Ultra instant
Goku on Planet Namek in ten hours but
that's not all immediately following
that I will attempt to recreate that
very same image in a one-hour drawing a
ten minute drawing after that and to cap
it all off I am going to attempt to
recreate my 10 hour drawing in just one
minute
cast your vote above do you believe in
me do you please give me your energy so
this what you're seeing right now is me
doing the sketch phase I do the sketch
phase just so that I have all
proportions in order so that when I do
the line art it's gonna be infinitely
easier some fun facts about me I'm 27
years old which means I've been drawing
for almost 39 years I would a drawing
competition when I was 7 school so
clearly this isn't my first ride around
a piece of paper so as you can see right
now having dedicated a decent chunk of
time to sketching I decided to move on
to the line art face which has been made
much much easier because I took the time
to do a proper sketch layer well I had
time to do it in the later ones who
knows stay tuned to find out
I like sketching helps my line art
lineup and what this 10 hour piece I had
plenty of time in fact I had so much
time this is about where I decided to
add a background I chose Namek because
it's really the only Dragonball
backgrounds that requires the least
amount of perspective while having loads
of detail and trust me you'll see that
but see I'm already taking shortcuts III
mean making stylistic choices yeah so
while I was drawing this I actually had
a load of different manga chapters open
just seeing how Toriyama decides to
shape things you'll notice that when I'm
drawing this I use a lot of cross
hatching and fading that's because
that's what Toriyama used around this
time actually like it it adds a nice bit
of detail while keeping a minimalistic
it's a really unique take I like it I
read it you might also notice I'm
skipping over a lot here but trust me
when the footage is 10 hours long and
you try to condense it down to just four
and a half minutes it sort of looks like
a flashy mess but don't worry I will
show all of the others from start to
finish and rest assured I use all of the
10 hours for this I accident
need that much time in order to utilize
all of that time I did what any sane
person would when preparing for a
time-sensitive challenge add even more
detail that's again why I chose Nanak as
the backdrop lots of lines and the rock
formations but I think I'm up to the
challenge so right here you see that I'm
adding the lines and detail for the hair
which is actually my favorite part of
doing any Dragonball drawing making
adjustments to the length of the torso
you might also notice that I keep
flipping the layer side-to-side that's
just so I can get a good idea of
portions that they're correct if I need
to make adjustments because this is the
final interphase and this is where you
need to make the last adjustments adding
some details on the pants and the boots
fixing some shading adjusting some stuff
this is all just me doing the final
polish for the lineart phase and once
the lineart phase is done we can move on
to the background so as you can see much
the same way as the original character
sketch layer I am using a sketch layer
for the environment because I might want
to change things on the final line art
face you'll notice that with this
particular ten-hour task I am being
overly cautious and taking as much time
as I possibly can to make sure all the
proportions and all the objects and
environments are in the correct place
this is just so the composition looks
nice and I have something to work off of
when I'm doing the one hour 10 minute
and one minute drawings so as I'm sure
you've noticed now the screen is kind of
going a bit crazy and that's because
behind the tablet I'm actually freaking
out because genius that I am I didn't
realize that I had given myself so
little time with so much work left to do
but I don't take any shortcuts I am
gonna give these rock formations all the
lights putting it a little bit more
detail on the background give the
horizon some love throw in a few suns I
mean you gotta include nameks three suns
I mean TFS did mention it and that's
pretty much the only reason I'm putting
in it that and it balances my
composition nicely so I do some
last-minute touch-ups pick some creases
and then we hop straight into the color
phase because I took the time to make
sure that all of my lines were connected
when I was doing the Polish colouring
became incredibly easy as I could just
select entire areas of his body and just
hit the fill button this ended up being
a huge time-saver with the little time I
have left I add some glow
and there it is the finished product
fully lined and fully colored that was
easy give me a challenge I'm gonna
redraw this even better in just 1 one
hour here we go oh also I'm pulling all
of these drawings so if you want to
click the icon above and cast your vote
did you think I did a good job that last
drawing so with this would our drawing
I'm not gonna lie for the first time in
my life I picked up my stylus and was
actually nervous with the time I had to
complete this task but I'm a brave boy I
dressed myself in the morning I pay my
taxes one leg at a time I've got this oh
also you might have noticed I didn't
actually finish that sketch layer and
that's because I set myself half an hour
to draw this Goku because I figured I
need the other half to do the background
in color so as I draw this line out
you'll see that I'm constantly making
adjustments because features aren't in
the right place and I kind of have to
eyeball everything which as you can well
imagine will most likely become a trend
the hair is probably my favorite part of
the whole drawing to draw or any drawing
really growing up when it was joined
Dragonball characters you know the hair
was sort of the thing that I started
drawing first
and so eyeballing the hair wasn't that
much of a hassle really with an art
style like Dragonball really the general
shape is the most important aspect of
the hair also I'd like to take this time
to say thank you so [ __ ] much to the
guy who invented the transform tool it
literally made this possible because I
had to skip a lot of the sketch layer
I had to eyeball pretty much everything
which meant that I had to make
adjustments on the way and if I didn't
have that transform tool I'd have to
erase everything and draw it again and
again and again until it's right at this
moment in time I'm starting to regret my
choices for making even the simplistic
design of Goku kind of complicated with
the cross hatching and the fade effects
but you know what so far it isn't too
bad I actually think it looks kind of
like the original gotta make sure Goku's
tits in place fixes back in his shoulder
and looks pretty good and now time to
draw the butt nice bit of crease work
there to emphasize the cheeks and oh
look there's a head oh yeah actually
member the head gave me a little bit of
trouble so I kind of just said you know
what I don't have so much time that time
to move out okay so the Pens
I actually do like drawing fabric it's
actually really cool in row morning when
you get the detail and the flow of it
right and as you can see I didn't really
get it for this one because you know I'm
realizing I have no time left seeing as
I've left myself 30 minutes
Goku and I'm pretty much coming close to
that already I decided to cut my losses
and just say you know what it's done
this is Goku I can't change any more I
finished up drawing the boots can you
move it a detail that last foot is
giving me a little bit of trouble and
yeah I mean come on
as thirty-minute Goku's go I mean that's
pretty I mean I'd [ __ ] that fix the leg
and oh and uh yeah I have to fix his
head so big but it's fine you know
everything's fine because we're moving
onto the background sketch layer you
know this is all gonna look fine you
know I've left myself half an hour that
should be plenty of time to do all the
rock formations and all the line and
detail work does that originally took me
seven hours to do yep all these shapes
are definitely correct and I didn't need
to go over a thousand more times to get
it anywhere near accurate but oh would
you look at the time but look it's you
know what it's fine this is a sketch
layer it should be fine
I allocated all my time carefully half
an hour to the Goku and half an hour to
that backer I get to go over this in the
lineart space everything is gonna be
look here we go so you look taking a
leaf out of pop frost drawing nice happy
little trees nice geometrically curious
rock formations everything is fine I
don't need more time this is all the
time I need time is for losers who needs
time when you got to talent like I do
ooh those lines don't look very good I
mean everything is fine and this is
exactly what I thought was gonna happen
it looks exactly like the original rice
yeah 100% look you know what it's not a
big deal
backgrounds don't matter that much I'm
sure once I get the collar on there
everything is gonna be fine once they
put the car on that the Lions warm-up
nearly as bad everything is gonna be
fine because I remembered to connect all
my lines when I did the Polish I didn't
do any Polish so this is gonna be fun I
didn't anticipate this either I had
completely forgotten that I needed to
connect all my lions and because I
didn't I now need to color everything by
hand like a coloring book in less than
10 minutes yeah as you can easily see I
decided to draw and color the background
in the style of Ed Edd and Eddy abstract
shapes with the colors outside the lines
this is clearly a stylistic choice and
definitely not because I was stupid
enough to
that 15 minutes was enough time to draw
and color a background you know what I
gotta remain positive you know I'm
backing this out getting all the happy
trees in there
coloring the ocean a nice puke yellow
yeah and look easy I'm even doing some
color polish you see that now that's
what a true Pro does fixing up the lines
making sure that I can make this look as
good as I can color the belt throw in
some lines to the hair because my
favorite part fix the eyebrows throwing
so glow and one two three John take that
virgin's yeah see perfect drawing not a
single line out of place you know what I
need a tougher challenge I'm gonna
recreate that 10 hour drawing in just 10
minutes and you know what who needs
sketch layers they were holding me back
anyway when you've got raw unbridled
talent like mine you can just eyeball it
look guys you don't understand I get it
the thing about being an artist is you
just got to be born with it you know I
can draw perfectly balanced eyes and
facial proportions
with the greatest of ease forget your
sullen yeah that was a that was a glitch
on my program I didn't actually make a
mistake that was just yeah just the the
program that I'm using just mostly
glitch yeah so yeah everything's fine
you know I got eight minutes left seven
minutes okay so yeah seven minutes left
look I'm just gonna bang out the hair
you know the hair that I love - oh looks
great again making no mistakes because
I'm a profession No yes oh look here
look we're drawing the hair you know we
got six minutes left that's plenty of
time to draw the rest of the body the
background and color but you know what
I'm up to the challenge let's do this as
you as you can see I'm foregoing all the
stylistic similarities to Toriyama
because you know really clear I mean
clearly this is better I mean it's a
it's a smoother more streamlined version
of a shintani style without any of the
shintani
if you think what I'm saying makes
absolutely no sense in that I'm an idiot
then really you're just a hater that has
no artistic vision just sit back and
enjoy the ride as I take you on a visual
journey oh and little known fact about
Goku he actually suffers from spinal
dysplasia
so I decided to emphasize that aspect in
his character design here for this one I
have no idea why I'm adjusting it here I
mean it's clearly perfect drawing his
blood get
Han droid perfect hand I mean I mean
that's I mean that's just like one would
go I mean I bind that at one go
fixing the shoulders even though they're
perfect yeah and fixing the head because
it was also perfect drawing the legs
obviously I've left loads of room to
draw the legs and you know what three
minutes is perfect amount of time to
draw all the legs collar it and draw the
background in that order at this point
in time I definitely wasn't freaking out
because I realized I had two and a half
minutes left
okay so we're drawing the other leg and
obviously you know keeping in mind that
the detail needs to be of the highest
quality
fixing legs doing that little bit of
extra work fixing the creases this is
all looking just great oh look I'm doing
a little bit of an adjustment because
I'm a [ __ ] professional and I found
the times somewhere I definitely don't
make a mistake there oh and also in the
blind panic that was the one minute left
I definitely wasn't freaking out so much
that I actually spilled water on me
disabling my ability to draw for about
30 seconds oh you know what who needs 30
seconds I can draw an entire background
in three seconds bang it out easy
jealous who needs color it's over what
what's happening my hands oh my god it's
help I'm channeling all your instinct I
can now draw without thinking
nothing is slowing me down now each pen
stroke perfectly placed and smooth I can
do this I can do this I've never drawn
better in my entire life it's it's
seamless flawless even no wasted motion
not a single mistake this is how Dragon
Ball was supposed to be drawn look at
this hair look at the line work how is
this possible
it looks amazing
[Music]
but what about the fit oh wow it's it's
perfect time for the background
one minute is plenty of time this is
what perfection looks like folks take
that virgins
[Music]
you
[Music]